no this isn't a runaway truck and no
it's not an outtake from the action
movie speed this is a conventional
18-wheeler that drives itself thanks to
a thirty thousand dollar retrofit San
Francisco startup Auto which Eber bought
this summer made history with this truck
it completed the world's first truck
autonomous delivery carrying 50,000 cans
of Budweiser from a brewery in Fort
Collins Colorado to Colorado Springs 120
miles away the human droves the truck
onto the highway flipped on self-driving
mode and spent the next two hours of
interstate chillin in the backseat
autonomous cars may get all the buzz but
teaching trucks to drive themselves
could deliver major economic and safety
benefits with three million drivers in
the u.s. trucks carry 70% of American
freight but there still aren't nearly
enough human drivers to do the job most
new drivers quit within a year and
because you people can't stop buying
stuff online demand is only going to go
up and that shortage will just get worse
in roughly 400,000 trucks crash every
year killing about 4,000 people and
costing the economy billions of dollars
human error is nearly always to blame
auto says the solution is a robot that
doesn't get tired angry drunk or
distracted so we're able to perceive
everything we're able to act faster and
as a result were able to make that truck
driver monitoring the system in the act
of driving much safer to take a
conventional truck and turn it into a
self-driving big reg autos gotta add
four key ingredients one is up top
that's a forward-facing camera this is
one of three lidar detection systems
that see the world with lasers much the
way radar works
speaking of radar you've got one of
those - this guy right here looks
hundreds of yards out ahead the fourth
key ingredient to making this truck
drive itself is giving it really good
understanding of the world and that
means detailed maps and once it's got
that it can combine it with the
information from the camera the lidar s
and the radar that give it a real-time
perception of the world all of that
together
makes it capable of understanding what's
going on around it and how to act
accordingly
later that morning I climbed into the
truck for a ride down Interstate 25 to
see how it works
and it performed flaws Otto's not the
only player here Daimler and Volvo are
testing their own autonomous semis and
the folks who need trucks to move their
stuff are already interested and if you
look at transportation we think that
self-driving technologies can improve
safety reduce emissions and improve
operational efficiencies of our
shipments but before auto can cash in on
the benefits of Robo trucking it has to
make sure its system will handle
anything that can happen on highway
construction bad weather cars spinning
out and over the next couple of videos
we'll continue to develop the technology
so it's actually ready to encounter
every condition on the road ultimately
the answer will be to remove the human
from the cab altogether and that means
losing jobs the driver will remain a
necessary part of the system at least
for the foreseeable future but with all
that extra time to relax on the road
maybe they can knock out a novel or two
or at least catch up on some sleep
[Music]